Hi zusammen!
Heute gibt's ein Rezept, dessen Namen ich nicht kenne weil mir das gestern Nacht eingefallen ist
und ich absolut keine Ahnung habe, wie ich diesen Kuchen bzw. diese Torte nennen soll!
[Hamza] Aber das ist doch voll authentisch!
Ja, also ich hab gestern Nacht - das war wirklich nachts! Um 23h habe ich angefangen
da kam mir 'ne Idee, bin von der Couch aufgestanden,
ab in die Küche und hab's schon mal ausprobiert und es gefällt mir mega, mega gut!
[Hamza] Und ich hab's gar nicht probiert!
Du hast es noch nicht probiert! Du weißt auch gar nicht, wie es aussieht, denn du hast gar nicht in den Kühlschrank geguckt
aber ich zeige euch das.
Und ich denke ihr werdet am Titel sehen wie es heißen wird
weil ich euch parallel auf Instagram frage, wie ich das Ganze denn nennen soll.
[Kiki] Also wir machen jetzt zuallererst einen No Bake-
[Hamza] Was wird das überhaupt?!
Genau, wollt' ich ja grad erklären! Also einen No Bake Kuchen, den viele auch kennen als Mosaik-Kuchen.
Ist so eher in der Türkei beliebt, gibt's auch - in der Türkei bei Starbucks und so gibt's das auch überall,
also der ist mega beliebt in der Türkei!
Und da drüber gibt es dann 2 Schichten Creme.
Eine ist schokoladig, die andere vanillig
und on top will ich noch einen Guss machen und dann ist es perfekt!
Wir fangen jetzt direkt an. Läuft die zweite Kamera?
Wunderbar! Also hier gebe ich in -
[Hamza] Sehe ich etwa unprofessionell aus?!
[Kiki] Doch, du siehst mega professionell aus!
[Hamza] Ja also!
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch immer unten in die Videobeschreibung,
die findet ihr direkt unter dem Titel.
Und da gebe ich jetzt hier zuallererst Milch rein.
So!
Und dann: Butter, die ich in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen habe, kommt auch noch mit dazu.
Anschließend Zucker und Backkakao.
Backkakao ist der stark entölte Kakao, nicht mit Trinkkakao verwechseln!
Wir brauchen die Konsistenz von diesem stark entölten Backkakao.
Das verrühre ich und gebe dann Kekse mit dazu.
Das sind ganz normale Butterkekse, die ich mit der Hand so ein bisschen zerkleinere.
So, unser Mosaik-Boden ist jetzt fertig und ihr habt jetzt 2 Möglichkeiten.
Entweder nehmt ihr euch so wie ich ein Cakeboard, gebt da eine Frischhaltefolie obendrauf
und dann einen Tortenring, den ich jetzt auf 22cm eingestellt habe.
Und wieso mache ich das? Auch ich habe in meinem Kühlschrank aktuell wenig Platz
und deshalb mache ich's nicht so, dass ich das direkt auf die Tortenplatte gebe. Das wäre nämlich Option 2!
Option 2 ist: Ihr nehmt einfach nur euren Tortenring ohne Frischhaltefolie
und gebt das direkt auf einen Tortenring.
[Hamza] Tortenplatte!
Aaah auf eine Tortenplatte! Ahh, sollen wir das nochmal neu drehen?
[Hamza] Nein, nein! *lacht*
[Kiki] Ok egal, ihr habt mich schon verstanden!
Also ich mach's jetzt so einfach weil ich keinen Platz aktuell im Kühlschrank habe!
[Hamza] Aber du merkst ich höre dir zu, ne?
Ja, das finde ich richtig toll!
So und jetzt gebt ihr einfach den Boden rein und streicht ihn dann schön glatt.
Jetzt gebt ihr den Mosaik-Boden bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank,
da wird er dann schön fest und er wird auch nochmal fester wenn wir dann die ganze Torte an sich nochmal kühlen.
Und ich habe jetzt hier die weiteren Zutaten.
Ganz wichtig ist, dass wir vorab erstmal die Schlagsahne steif schlagen.
Dafür muss die Sahne ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank kommen.
Ihr könnt sie nicht erstmal stehen lassen und dann irgendwann benutzen
sondern die ist jetzt eiskalt und auch meine Schüssel ist nicht warm, also die ist auch relativ kalt
und mein Schneebesen ebenso.
Und das ist jetzt mein Unterschied zu meinen anderen Rezepten:
Hier benutze ich jetzt kein Sahnefest und ich erkläre euch auch gleich warum,
schlage das Ganze jetzt aber auf maximaler Geschwindigkeit schön steif.
So, die Sahne ist jetzt steif. Achtet darauf, dass ihr sie nicht überschlagt und sie nicht gerinnt,
dann müsst ihr das nämlich nochmal erneut aufschlagen und das wäre mega ärgerlich!
Das hat jetzt bei mir in der Küchenmaschine nur 80sek gedauert.
Ich mache jetzt weiter, jetzt habe ich hier -
Also ich mache 2 verschiedene Cremes, das habe ich euch grad schon am Anfang erzählt
und zwar habe ich hier Doppelrahmfrischkäse und - also in 2 verschiedenen Schüsseln!
Hier habe ich schon gerade in der Mikrowelle bei geringer Wattzahl
einmal Zartbitterkuvertüre und weiße Kuvertüre geschmolzen.
Jetzt ist es ganz, ganz wichtig damit es bei euch Zuhause auch gelingt
und ihr keine Stückchen habt und das Ganze auch schon mousse-artig wird,
dass A) der Frischkäse schon ein bisschen runtergekommen ist auf Zimmertemperatur,
den habe ich 1h vorher aus dem Kühlschrank genommen.
Und B) auch mega, mega wichtig:
dass die geschmolzene Kuvertüre ebenfalls runtergekühlt ist. Sie darf nicht mehr warm sein!
Und wenn beide Zutaten eine ähnliche Temperatur haben, dann verbindet sich das auch viel besser
und ihr bekommt keine Stückchen.
Und jetzt rühre ich einmal die Zartbitterkuvertüre hier in meinen Frischkäse
und das gleiche mache ich auch mit der weißen Kuvertüre.
Zur dunklen Mousse habe ich noch Zucker gegeben und zur hellen Mousse noch Vanilleextrakt.
Und jetzt kommt jeweils die Hälfte der aufgeschlagenen Sahne mit dazu und wird noch unterge- untergehoben!
[Hamza] Untergejubelt!
[Kiki] Untergejubelt, genau!
So, jetzt sind beide Cremes fertig und ich hoffe, ihr konntet mir auch bis hierhin folgen.
Ich versuche alles immer so kleinschrittig und genau wie möglich zu erklären.
Und falls ihr an der Stelle fragt, stellt sie mir unter das Video und dann kommentiere ich auch.
Egal, wie alt das Video ist, ich schaue immer in die Kommentare rein, um euch zu helfen.
[Kiki] Jetzt habe ich mir meinen Tortenring aus dem Kühlschrank genommen -
[Hamza] Oder die Kikimunity hilft!
Oder - sehr guter Einwand! - die Kikimunity hilft auch untereinander!
Das finde ich auch immer so schön! Lese ich einen Kommentar, dann will ich drauf antworten, dann hat jemand anderes schon geholfen!
Ihr seid so toll!
Also ich gebe jetzt hier erstmal die dunkle Mousse auf meinen Mosaik-Boden,
streiche das glatt und streiche dann die Vanille-Mousse glatt.
Und guckt mal: Und das ist der Grund, warum ich kein Sahnefest wollte!
Und das wird nach dem Festwerden noch, noch, noch cremiger!
[Hamza] Das sieht soo cremig aus!
[Kiki] M-hm, richtig lecker!
So, jetzt habe ich die Vanillecreme auch noch oben verstrichen, schön glatt gemacht und jetzt kommt sie in den Kühlschrank.
Jetzt müsst ihr wirklich Geduld haben weil noch ist das alles sehr, sehr weich
und wenn ihr jetzt den Tortenring entfernen würdet, würde euch alles zerlaufen,
Daher gebt dem Ganzen ganz viel Kälte!
Am besten dann im Kühlschrank aufbewahren für 5h, gerne auch über Nacht!
Also ihr könnt das super, super gut am Vortag schon vorbereiten!
Und bei mir kommt ganz am Ende noch eine Schokoglasur oben drauf,
dann hat sie für mich auch so optisch das perfekte Erscheinungsbild
aber das ist natürlich auch euch überlassen!
Was ich mir auch gut vorstellen kann ist z.B. eine Fruchtglasur obendrauf
aber ich wollte den Kuchen jetzt komplett einmal schokoladig lassen.
Also wir sehen uns dann nach der Kühlzeit wieder und dann zeige ich euch, wie der Schokoguss geht.
Für die Schokoglasur nehmen wir uns jetzt Sahne und erwärmen sie in einem Topf
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr sie nicht aufkochen lasst sondern wirklich nur erwärmt
und da geben wir dann gehackte Vollmilchkuvertüre dazu.
Und sobald sich das zu einer Masse verbunden hat, nochmal 8-10min stehen lassen
damit's nicht ganz so warm ist und anschließend so wie ich das jetzt mache
einfach vorsichtig auf die Oberfläche geben und dann schön schwenken.
So und jetzt ist die Torte fertig bzw. wir müssen nur noch oben den Guss einmal fest werden lassen.
Das dauert nicht lange, also 15-20min, ihr dürft's auch gerne wieder zurück in den Kühlschrank geben.
Und die Torte hält sich insgesamt 4 Tage, das heißt ihr könnt sie super am Vortag zubereiten
und dann habt 3 Tage Zeit, sie zu verspeisen aber ich glaube, so lange hält die gar nicht!
Wir machen auf jeden Fall gleich noch den Taste Test, daher bleibt auf jeden Fall dran, wenn ihr das sehen möchtet!
Und ja, ich würde mal sagen ich richte das jetzt gleich erstmal schön an und dann sehen wir uns nachher wieder!
[Hamza] Das ist geil!
[Kiki] Hamza?
[Kiki] Bereit für den Taste Test?
[Hamza] Auf jeden Bro!
[Hamza] *mit amerikanischem Akzent* Der Taste Test is here! Oh my goodness! Whoo!
*beide lachen*
[Hamza] So! Erklär mal Kiki: Was hast du da gezaubert?
[Kiki] Das ist eine No Bake Torte mit einem Mosaik-Boden..
[Hamza] No Bake Torte? Oh my God!
[Kiki] ..einer Zartbitter-Mousse..
[Hamza] Zartbitter-Mousse!
[Kiki] einer weißen Vanille-Mousse..
[Hamza] Weiße Vanille-Mousse!
[Kiki] ..und einer Vollmilchglasur!
[Hamza] Achso sorry, das ist die Vollmilchglasur!
[Kiki] Ja! *lacht*
[Hamza] Vergesst alles, ich bin einfach verwirrt!
[Hamza] So, und das ist dann - der Boden ist aus Keksen, ne?
[Kiki] Der Boden ist aus - also wirklich, man muss sagen der Boden ist relativ leicht...
[Kiki] ..denn es ist keine Sahne mit drin! Ein bisschen Butter und zum größten Teil halt Milch, das macht's halt aus.
[Hamza] So! Auch wenn ich grad echt kindisch bin - ich hab grade meine 5 Minuten, ihr habt grad Pech!
[Hamza] So, ich geh - Boah... boah!
[Hamza] Habt ihr's gesehen? Habt ihr's gesehen wie ich reingegangen bin?
[Kiki] Zeig mal!
[Hamza] Guck mal! Als ob ich in einen Hauch von Nichts reingegangen bin!
[Kiki] Krass!
[Hamza] Boah, guck mal, guck mal, guck mal! Diese Gabel! Diese Spur von der Gabel!
[Hamza] Mach doch gleich Kamera kaputt!
[Kiki] Ich mach grad die krassesten Aufnahmen!
[Hamza] Echt? Die sind bestimmt unscharf!
[Kiki] Nein!
[Hamza] So, ich probiere jetzt! Riecht gut!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Kiki] Deine Mimik zeigt, wie du ihn findest!
[Hamza] Boah! Boah! Explosion im Mund, boah!
[Kiki] Heftig, ne?
[Hamza] Oben ist es so weich und unten so ein bisschen härter, so ein bisschen... Boah, mega!
[Hamza] Auch nicht zu süß! Dadurch, dass hier so 3 verschiedene Schokoschichten sind ist das auch nicht zu süß!
[Hamza] Also ich finde das mega! Von der Konsistenz her, das zergeht im Mund richtig!
[Hamza] Ich muss sagen ich gebe dafür echt eine 10 von 10!
[Kiki] Boaah! *lacht*
[Hamza] Ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung, warum ich überhaupt so ein Barometer mache! Das gibt eine 10 von 10!
[Kiki] Heftig!
[Hamza] Der ist heftig der Kuchen, wirklich!
[Kiki] Krass!
[Hamza] Leute, ohne Spaß, ich sage zwar immer: "Boah, ist heftig! Schmeckt gut, schmeckt gut!" aber Kiki, ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll! Der schmeckt einfach!
[Hamza] Es schmeckt einfach! Das ist schwierig für euch, ja, aber es schmeckt!
[Hamza] Kiki's Rezepte sind einfach çok güzel!
[Kiki] Darf ich jetzt kommen?
[Hamza] Du darfst jetzt kommen Kiki!
[Kiki] Ich komme!
[Hamza] Aber ich esse alleine, du isst dein eigenes Stück!
[Kiki] Ja, mein Stück steht hier. Und unser Kaffee!
[Hamza] Mmmh!
*beide lachen*
[Hamza] Ich schwör's euch: Geil!
[Kiki] Also! Wo muss ich reingucken? Ach da!
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Ich bin richtig aufgeregt!
[Kiki] Obwohl ich den Geschmack ja kenne. Ich kenne die einzelnen Komponenten aber...egal!
[Kiki] Boah! Ey...unnormal!
[Hamza] Heftig! Heftig, ne?
[Kiki] Unnormal, unnormal, unnormal!
[Kiki] Ich sag euch, was daran so krank ist!
[Hamza] Was ist krank?
[Kiki] Das Kranke ist: dieser Boden unten, der gibt schon genug Süße ab.
[Kiki] Dann habe ich im Zartbitter Bereich ja wirklich nur ein Esslöffelchen Zucker auf den ganzen Kuchen gegeben..
[Kiki] ...und hier oben gar keinen zusätzlichen Zucker, gar keinen Zucker!
[Hamza] Deswegen sage ich ja es ist auch nicht zu süß!
[Kiki] Das schmeckt überhaupt nicht mächtig!
[Hamza] Du hast da was!
[Kiki] Was denn? Eine Wimper? Dann darf ich mir was wünschen!
[Kiki] Eine Wimper?
[Hamza] Ich hab gehört das bringt Glück: oben oder unten?
[Kiki] Ähm..oben!
[Hamza] Sieht man das? Das hat mir Kiki beigebracht!
[Hamza] Oben? Okay. Du sagst oben, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Kiki] Die ist gar nicht mehr da!
[Hamza] Hä, wo ist die?
[Kiki] Gehen wir nach hause, echt!
[Hamza] Also wenn sie oben gewesen wäre, dann dürfte Kiki einmal pusten und sich was wünschen, ne?
[Hamza] Das hast du mir so beigebracht!
[Kiki] Ja! Ich hab das als Kind von irgendjemandem so gehört.
[Hamza] Ich find das ist voll der Mist aber..
[Kiki] Ja, ist es auch!
[Hamza] Aber süß!
[Kiki] Naja! Was ich jetzt noch ein- ein...
[Hamza] *stottert*
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Kiki] Was ich euch noch mitgeben möchte - und da stimmst du mir auch bestimmt zu!
[Kiki] Mit diesem Kuchen kann man Herzen erobern, oder?
[Hamza] Mit diesem Kuchen - also ganz ehrlich Leute, ne? Also vor allem an die Damen da draußen:
[Hamza] Wenn ihr zur Schwiegermutter geht oder zu eurer zukünftigen Schwiegermutter - die wird euch lieben dafür!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Ach weißt du was? Zu eurem Verlobten oder zu eurem Mann - die werden euch lieben dafür, ich schwör's euch!
[Hamza] Also ich liebe dich dafür!
*beide lachen*
[Hamza] Also ich liebe Kiki dafür, dass sie so tolle Kuchen backt! Ehrlich!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Heftiger Kuchen! Wirklich, ich meine das ernst!
[Hamza] Ich übertreibe nicht, der ist echt heftig!
[Kiki] Der schmeckt super leicht!
[Hamza] Leute macht's nach! Und zum Abschluss?
[Kiki] Ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
[Kiki] Macht das Video, kommt zurück zum Video und hinterlasst uns Feedback unten in den Kommentaren.
[Kiki] Und dann würden wir mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal, Tschüss!
[Kiki] Und guckt euch mal unsere Tür an!
[Kiki] Das ist unsere Übergangstür, ein großer Karton!
[Hamza] Peace and out!
[Kiki] Egal, Hauptsache wir haben Kuchen!
[Kiki] Wer braucht schon eine Tür wenn wir einen Kuchen haben?
[Kiki] Tschüüss!
[Hamza Tschüüss!]